thanks to halo on paramount plus for
sponsoring a portion of this video there
are many things that are satisfying in
life
[Music]
we have to try our best to make
something that is as satisfying as
physically possible if you guys can make
me feel the way it feels when i do this
i know who had the most satisfying
render
it's that guy
who's here
whoa jesus
oh hey man
that was
yo
oh my god are you totally just picking
oh my god
no i'm good i'm good i just hit my head
really really hard i guess
it's a good one jay would you like me
and he just said render challenge
question mark i replied with why
not like why but like yes of course i'm
coming down render challenge i'm here
well it's not just any render challenge
you see our satisfaction levels are at
an all-time low we hate life right now
and we need something to carry us out of
this pit of despair you know i'm still
reeling from the gross render challenge
we did i couldn't watch like half of
those seriously like i watched as far as
i could was it peter's neck dude gross
that came right after the unsatisfying
render challenge too
you know what are we doing we're letting
you guys down we're letting ourselves
down so i think this time around we have
to truly try our best to make something
that is as satisfying as physically
possible the visual is nice and clean
and scratches the correct itch combined
with sound design and probably the most
important thing of all
it's got a loop
that way the satisfaction never ends
here's the thing like the loop is
definitely an element that makes it more
satisfying but it's one of many elements
you can use to make it satisfy yeah for
me the perfect fit is like very
satisfying extremely satisfying i think
like a thick cut is nice
anything that kind of shows something
being completed machinery working to
perfection loop ability look at this i'm
built for it
you know nice sound design that's huge
for me clint you did that singing bowls
one
[Music]
chef's kiss okay we're gonna meet right
back here in one week and i expect at
that time to be satisfied okay ready
three two one
recently i've been watching all these
like bmx videos by this dude danny
something they're incredible and he just
makes these moves look so effortless and
he's hitting these jumps it's very
satisfying so my idea is to
make a skate park with a bunch of sweet
jumps and a bunch of sweet tricks and
you're hitting the perfect air getting
the perfect landing my main goal with
this satisfying render is time
management oh my god time management i'm
not the best at it let's just be honest
i'm not the best at it sometimes
originally yes i wanted to do a bmx
thing but getting like the feet
connected to the pedals and having the
wheels turn at the right rate just was
way too much so instead of a bike i'm
gonna do a skateboard because i don't
have time for a bike and i need to build
out the actual ramp setup so i use the
spline to draw out the actual ramp and
the path and then i used that same
spline just with a little bit of an
ellipse right at the top for the
skateboarder at first i went too
ambitious i had loops in there and stuff
now let's just do two jumps one final
little ramp and it's looped i set up a
nice ik rig between the feet and the
hips and everything so we can have the
skateboarder stuck and down and hand
animated the arms so basically once i
had a version animated i knew i was safe
and i got that on day two which
is the best feeling ever because i took
the other two days to just spice it up i
made the lighting nice i made the
textures nice i focused on the
background a little bit and i even had
time to add some details like the flag
in the foreground and some birds
scattered throughout and that's about it
really it was just managing my time i've
been in boats where i have just been off
way more than i can chew and i did not
want to do this this time around so i'm
very proud of how it turned out and i
hope you guys like it as well
so you know when i was thinking about
what would be a cool satisfying render i
had this weird flashback to when i was a
kid and i walked by the toy store and
they had this small duck toy thing and
the ducks would kind of just go up the
stairs and they'd go down the slide and
it was like really relaxing to just
watch them go forever and i thought what
would be a really fun kid's toy that i
could make that my younger self would
really have enjoyed what if i make this
eternally looping a little catapult
system for basketball where these shots
are constantly being made perfectly
every single time building that was a
little bit of a challenge which i did
through the use of volume modeling for
each of these slides i used what's
called a spline and i swept across that
spine to make a slide then halfway
through the slide i created a second
spline branching off it and ran that
same slide shape across that so now i
have these branching slides coming from
the same point once this was built it
actually came down to simulating now i
didn't want to do the hand animating
thing i actually wanted this to work to
create catapults that could actually
launch balls into the hoop i gave them
what's called an inherent velocity i set
aside about a half day to just shoot
hoops digitally right i made it in the
second shot
i don't know how it happened
colby and since the entire hoop and net
is plastic it's very rigid it doesn't
move around it bounces and it rattles
and it goes through the hole and it's
really satisfying but that leaves of
course the final stage which is to
actually get them to blend properly
right timing and so what i did i thought
it might be the best approach instead of
doing all five separately i only did the
slides on the right half and the slide
down the middle which meant i got to
mirror the catapults and the balls so
now you have 10 balls in perfect sync
with one another and they loop perfectly
because it's all timed to be identical
kind of makes you feel like i did the
first time i walked past that toy store
and saw my first small duck
i have a special guest coming in the
studio actually who's coming or is it a
secret i don't know i have no idea i'm
kind of scared actually what's happening
i guess we should answer it let me do
the honors
oh my god this portion of today's video
is sponsored by the halo series on
paramount plus master chiefs here to
save the day and to tell you guys all
about the new incredible halo live
action series inspired by the original
2001 halo the game which was of course
only on xbox i don't know if you were
around for that you probably weren't
even born yet kid wow i'm already so
hyped about this hey someone's
terrifying
master chief first name last name
situation first name master last name da
chief dude matt wow you're my greatest
hero you're probably a huge fan of the
halo universe since i was a child yeah
literally guess what now you can go to
paramountplus.com and you can watch halo
the series no way wow and i'm in it wow
you're in it yes mr chief himself look
nice i can jump up and down
you know how you guys are here doing
cool satisfying renders yeah yeah all
the time well in the halo live action
show there's a lot of cool shots in
there satisfying shots satisfying
covenant kills super satisfying ren what
is one thing you love about some of your
greatest movies good storytelling
exactly and you know where a good story
comes from video games no well yes but
you know why it's a good story because
it's got deeply woven personal drama
that hits you right there in the
heartstrings that's why and halo the
series has exactly that they've got
deeply woven personal stories between a
centuries-old conflict between humanity
and an alien race known as the covenant
you combine the visual effects with
those deep personal stories and it's
like guys i mean what's better
they repair that back at the ship it's
fine did you know christian that the
series also stars pablo schreiber as
master chief himself natasha mcalhone as
dr halsey and then there's also jen
taylor who of course plays cortana
cortana is the most advanced ai in the
history of humanity and she could
potentially be
the source of all
life
saving
sources she could potentially save earth
all right everybody master chiefs done
here i got to go fight the covenant but
if you guys are interested in checking
out halo the series go to
paramountplus.com or just click the link
in the description below try it for free
and remember halo is exclusively on
paramount plus right now thanks again to
halo on paramount plus for sponsoring
this portion of the video and uh hey
finish the fight
find the halo win the war
[Music]
so for this one you know i think we were
kind of talking about the sound design a
lot i don't know why i got in my head
that it would be really satisfying to
get that kind of you know that sound
once a drain finishes all the water
drains out of a sink or sometimes a
toilet and i wanted to kind of play
around with doing like a liquid
simulation here and basically have the
corridor logo melt and then reform into
itself so kind of that idea of like
molten metal satisfying that idea of
like you know a liquid becoming a solid
i was kind of inspired by the new lord
of the rings rings of power how that
whole intro was done practically i was
like how would i film this practically
so kind of trying to emulate that it was
really tricky
because i haven't done a ton of
simulation so i ended up having a 3d
modeled corridor logo here i basically
then used flip fluid simulation to
essentially create a fluid sim that then
poured through a little funnel that i
created into a mold of the corridor logo
again as this is happening the camera's
pushing forwards and doing kind of like
a hitchcock zoom so the focal length is
adjusting at the same time it's pushing
in and then by the end of this we've got
basically a liquid version of our
quarter logo again it was a definitely a
fun experiment it was one of those
things where i wanted to push myself a
little bit while still at the same time
being able to achieve what i wanted and
i was pretty happy with the final result
and
i think some of the guys might be a
little bit satisfied
there are many things that are
satisfying in life it's like a peaceful
tickling almost you know it's like
visuals sounds feelings
they all contribute to
a satisfying feeling another thing is
inspiration i take inspiration from
literally everywhere last week cinema 4d
released their newest version and with
that comes a brand new simulation system
for cloths and ropes so now the problem
of like what is satisfying about cloth
well it didn't take long for me to
realize that cloth ripping has a very
distinct sound to it it's like just
sharp enough to be like almost
annoying but it's tempered just enough
to be satisfying what if i have like a
long tall cloth and i have a knife
puncture through it and then rip all the
way down and then pull out and i just
have an animated camera go from top to
bottom at a very consistent rate so that
i can take that exact same render and
line it up with itself to loop forever
traditionally cloth sims take a very
long time but look at this
this is simulating in real time and it's
ripping did you see that crap
but what if i don't want it to rip in
all those different places what if i
specifically want it to rip down the
middle if i just select some of these
polygons here like that when i go to
select
set vertex weight and under tearing i
can take my vertex map and put it in
here and now in theory it should rip
only where i told it to look at that how
cool is that so now you can actually art
direct exactly where it rips that will
allow me to get a very controlled cut
exactly where i need it to be i didn't
want to just have the knife come in and
then like drop down and leave again it
needed a little bit of personality and i
can go through and keyframe animate that
or i can you know do some mocap
literally what i did for this whole
sequence right here i just pretended
that a knife is sticking out of the end
of my phone here and i was like
you're here
[Music]
and just like that i animated a knife
but i had to go through and like upload
all the footage to my computer even
though i didn't use any of the footage i
just took the camera that was animated
and parented this knife to it it was a
very manual process but it wasn't that
bad it's just like it could be so much
simpler and this actually
oh my god i've literally been in contact
with the developers at cinema 4d i am
desperate for this feature to be a thing
remember the whole stained glass man
video we put out like a month or two ago
i shot all those scenes with my phone
and it was able to camera track the
footage in real time and there's a bunch
of different apps that do that they're
great but this one allowed it to
actually directly upload to a server and
then down to my computer without me
having to do anything and so this made
it really nice to be able to get that
footage to my computer already tracked
scene already set up i want to be able
to just use my phone as a puppet i want
to use this as sort of like a point in
space that is recording positional and
rotational data and have that go to the
computer so you guys at cinema 4d i
desperately need this and i'm hoping
that maybe this call to action will help
you incorporate this fully into the
software we have the technology to make
this happen let's do it but you know
what fenner jordan i'm excited to see
you guys renders let's do this
okay it has been a week and we have now
reassembled to check out our final
satisfaction that's the right way to say
it right if you guys can make me feel
the way it feels when i do this
it's going to be like that minus the
effort i am in
particular need of some calming
satisfaction right now because i've had
a hell of a morning trying to get this
final thing put together i just need to
do the simplest of like mask transitions
and i spent about two hours
troubleshooting it with after effects
crashing on me over a hundred times so
mark my words as of right now unless
after effects gets rewritten from the
ground up
i'm not using it anymore
yo what up nico i just got off the
business call and boy am i stressed out
it should be great if there's just some
cool runners playing on this tv that
were perfect for making me chill all
right fenner's first
or rather he's going first
let's see
i'm pretty satisfied that was that was
nice i like the fluid sim you got going
on it's really nice it's very
mesmerizing yeah i could stare at that
for a long time i like the spladouche
that initially it's actually you know
what it is it's actually a defibrillator
you know what until i see my render up
here i'm not going to be comfortable
enough to be satisfied by anyone else so
this is what i've got
oh
[Music]
dude
that's good
when the knife pushes through you see
wobbling and then it pushes through like
if you look at it you can actually see
the tension
and then it pushes through this might be
more satisfying than the puzzle
definitely more pieces than the puzzle
pieces really
when the knife leaves them the cloth is
like already deformed and stretched and
saggy everything about this is so cool i
think there's static electricity on the
knife
yeah i mean
okay i got mine out of the way i can i'm
done i can relax i can be satisfied
skateboarding this one's for you right
get there swim
perfect
yeah
it's a nice loop i really like the
swimming this little like just inertia
just trying to get back up to the top
i'm glad because that was totally what i
would do if i was yeah yeah
in her shoes i would do that same thing
it really feels like i'm up in a dream
like on this also that perspective where
you think they're about to go off the
edge and then they fall and you see the
ramp the last second it's very tasty and
we gotta shout out the fact that there's
you know wind simulation on those flags
and threw in there those little details
oh yeah the droppings from the pigeons
are they're dropping from the pigeons i
don't even notice wait what the pigeon
drops oh wow you're right yeah nice dude
that was the last thing i added
the droppings it's all about the sound
too man the trucks the trucks on the
wood just
man i'm so close to being fully
satisfied just not quite enough
oh
basketball
[Applause]
wow
this one was checking all the boxes for
me man all the little clicks all the
little
all the balls dude
my favorite part is that ball in the
middle the ball just perfectly pops out
right before the next one comes out all
of this is uh physics simulation work i
was gonna ask that was my first question
was is this simulated yeah the whole
thing it's sweet man so it works it
works yeah it's it's a working machine i
think that gives me the most
satisfaction in this render is your
insistence on having camford edges
thank you for noticing it's like
somebody took a cookie cutter into dough
and
man i'm so satisfied right now i'm way
too biased to judge this nico you're an
unbiased party here you didn't do a
render for this who had the most
satisfying render
i know who had the most satisfying
render
it's that guy
wait did i oh heck yeah
oh thank you thank you
i mean they're all really good but uh
you know i've seen a lot of slicing
but this i haven't seen anything like it
i'm so frustrated by how my morning went
that it's hard for me to accept this but
thank you i mean the real winner here is
the entire rest of the world now that
they get to watch these animations
how different they all were too like i
feel like none of us really hit that
same kind of thing but they're all
satisfying in their own special way for
real though my favorite things
toilets skateboards and basketball
guys i think that you each satisfied me
to completion to the point where
i don't think i need this anymore i'm
retiring
my little ding dong
i'm not gonna lie though after all that
satisfaction
still not enough i need you guys to
subscribe that'll leave me with the
ultimate subscriptions
faction subscribe to fulfill our dreams
listen we love doing these render
challenges we're trying to think of like
fun alternate ideas on this whole idea
and i think we need some comments
suggesting them leave a comment
you know you know what to do